de passage au Yukon ou un des engins
volants a été abattu Justin Trudeau sert
un avertissement nous prenons ça
extrêmement sérieux et tente d’apaiser
les craintes des Canadiens je peux vous
assurer que la sécurité la souveraineté
l'intégrité de l'espace aérien de
l'Amérique du Nord est une préoccupation
primordiale mais de nombreuses questions
persistent sur la capacité du Canada à
se protéger de ce genre de menace alors
que quatre engins volants ont 10 jours
ont pénétré l'espace aérien
nord-américain c'est quand même assez je
vous dirais d'un point de vue sécurité
après le 11 septembre que l'espace
aérien soit aussi poreux d'abord les
radars vieillissants de norades ne sont
pas toujours calibrés pour détecter ces
petits objets qui avancent lentement
pour le Canada tous les systèmes de
défense Canada sont en piètre état et ce
sont des chasseurs américains qui ont
abattu les engins au-dessus du Yukon et
du concurrents parce qu'ils étaient les
plus près mais les avions de chasse
Canadiens ont quand même des capacités
limitées
encore plus performantes qui peuvent
aller au-dessus le Premier ministre lui
estime que NORAD est un travail d'équipe
par qui reçoit le crédit pour ça et
beaucoup plus préoccupé par le résultat
qu'on veut c'est comme ça que a été
constitué nos reins le mystère des
objets volants non identifiés s'étend du
Grand Nord au grand lac et ses engins
sont d'origine humaine insiste la Maison
Blanche
assure la porte-parole de Joe Biden
malgré les théories qui circulent sur
les réseaux sociaux le Canada et les
États-Unis collaborent maintenant pour
récupérer les épaves des engins abattus
maintenant nous sommes en train de faire
un examen et de sous pression sur le
terrain retrouver les épaves et
cruciales pour élucider le mystère c'est
quoi les objets c'est quel genre de
technologie est-ce que ça faisait partie
du même programme est-ce que c'est
différent est-ce que ça vient de
d'autres pays ces nouveaux engins
volants viennent-ils eux aussi de la
Chine ou d'un autre pays comme la Corée
du Nord ou la Russie qui voudrait tester
les systèmes de défense nord-américains
une chose est certaine si des failles
ont été exposées elles devront être
colmatées ici Christian Noël
Radio-Canada Ottawa